we're going to start the final session
now and so the the final guest to
speaking is Roger cornberg who's a
professor of structural biology at
Stanford Medical School and I think most
of you know Roger comes from a
distinguished scientific family but has
made many important contributions uh on
his own in fact in backtack papers in
1974 he announced the discovery of the
nucleosome which you heard about earlier
today and that work was done with
Francis Crick and Aaron clug in the same
laboratory where Sid began his work on
on TRNA and in his own laboratory Roger
has done obviously very important work
looking at the structure of the
transcriptional apparatus and in
particular solving that structure to the
atomic resolution of RNA pimas 2
transcribing DNA into messenger RNA a
fundamental process in biology so it's
terrific to uh welcome him he won the
Nobel Prize in 20 6 for this work and
it's great to be for him to be the final
speaker at today's
Symposium so uh thank you Dan and uh let
me add to what others have said what a
privilege and pleasure it is uh to
congratulate you Sid to participate in
this celebration of your work um unlike
the others who were either a teacher or
a fellow student or ultimately uh a
student of yours uh I represent the rest
of the world um all of the many
additional admirers of your
work uh I will uh in the brief time that
is available uh speak primarily about uh
two subjects I'll begin with an
introduction showing you just a view of
the RNA PL R 2 pre-initiation complex
and this is the work of Kenji morakami
near kalisman David Bushnell and then a
former post-doctoral fellow who's been
at scripts for many years Francisco
hisus and his postdoctoral fellow kuang
Le Sai um I'll spend most of the time
after that introduction
uh speaking about the transcription of
Chromatin and all of this work is due to
shigeki nagai if time permits I'll
comment briefly on a point that Mark
patach raised um and in this respect
work done by Yi lch and Barbara Mayor
Davis and then I hope to leave time at
the end for a second subject uh and that
is the folding of Chromatin fibers
beyond the level of the nucleosome uh in
this case the work of Kyle Eagan and Tom
harle
now as I've mentioned and you heard from
Dan and you're all doubtless aware um
all that I tell you relates to
transcription by one of the three
polymerases of eukariotic cells RNA
polymerase 2 and uh many of you are
doubtless aware of what Mar Mark
diagrammed in one of his slides namely
the components of the pimas 2
transcription Machinery which we and
others identify by now some 30 years ago
uh the polymerase
itself is capable alone of unwinding the
DNA double helix and of RNA synthesis
but alone unable to recognize a start
site and initiate the process of
transcription and it is for those
essential functions that it requires the
so-called General transcription factors
that go by the letter names bde e f and
H now it was a thought for some time
that this constellation of proteins is
not only sufficient uh for the
initiation of transcription for promoter
dependent transcription but sufficient
also for a response to regulatory
influences and
indeed um as Mark would attest if he
were here uh it was there were many
proofs of that point of direct
interaction of transcriptional activat
proteins with components of this
Machinery published during the
1980s nevertheless in the early 90s my
colleagues uh kellaher Flanigan him and
Borland discovered an additional
component required for an influence of a
transcriptional activator protein such
as Mark mentioned upon the transcription
Machinery that I have just
described U this they isolated uh from
yeast as a 21 protein million molecular
complex we now know that it is conserved
throughout ukar uh we refer to it as
mediator for the obvious reason that it
goes between Reg regulatory molecules
both activators and repressors and the
transcription
machinery and we now know uh that some
60 proteins assemble in a large complex
of about 3 million Dalton at every RNA
polymerase to promoter prior to every
round of
transcription to understand the
mechanism of the Machinery uh we began
long ago to investigate its structure
and we started Ed as you will have heard
with the pyase itself an assembly of a
dozen subunits with a mass greater than
half a million Daltons and far larger
than could even be uh solved at the time
when we started but the process when it
finally culminated uh after about 15
years LED as you've heard to the
structure of the pimas in the act of
transcription with both Gene DNA and
product RNA Associated at near Atomic
resolution another 15 years later later
uh we finally succeeded in assembling
the entire complex of plas with all of
the general
factors uh an assembly of uh in the form
that we studied about one and a half
megadaltons and just last year could
report the uh structure determined by
cryo electron microscopy um as shown in
this slide so what you see here um is
first of all a space filling model so an
envelope of the entire structure of this
33 protein
complex uh as determined by cry electon
microscopy and then superimposed on that
uh envelope are the crystal structures
of the polymerase in Gray of the general
transcription factors B which is red the
crystal structure of the tatab Box
binding uh subunit of factor D which is
green uh Factor e in pink factor F in
blue and up the portion of factor H for
which Crystal structures have been
determined uh superimposed as well and
you see that there's really a very
impressive near Perfect Fit of the
crystal structure pimas and of the other
Crystal structures to the map uh in
addition one sees the DNA uh and at this
resolution the major and minor grooves
of the DNA in uh even resolved and what
I'll show you in the next picture is a
view down the axis of the DNA double
helix so we rotate this around you view
down the axis of the DNA double helix in
this picture also superimposed um is
just one of the crystal structures that
of the uh ATP dependent DNA helicase
subunit of factor H which is responsible
for unwinding the double helix to bring
about the initiation of
transcription the notable feature of
this picture is the lack of any
interaction of polymerase with the DNA
and a polymer preinitiation complex
indeed the DNA is associated only with
the general factors and uh if there were
time I would explain why that is and in
more detail the significance but I'd
like to go on if there were time I would
also show you uh a cryan picture of not
only pyase and the general factors but
also mediator um but rather what I'd
like to do is explain in the time I have
this afternoon um why this picture even
that of the polymerase General factors
and mediator is
incomplete and the Assembly of proteins
responsible for the initiation of
transcription of all genes transcribed
by pmer 2 is a good deal larger more
complex and uh I think more
interesting now the reason uh why the
structure proves to be much more
complicated than we realized is because
of a mistaken assump asson that we and
others have made over the years uh we
always thought that the template for
assembly of this complex and for
transcription is a naked DNA molecule
and there was good reason to believe so
uh I mean uh in the first place um I
think it's obvious that the DNA can't be
at the same time surrounded as you see
here by all of the components of the
pre-initiation complex and at the same
time wrapped around a set of eight
histone molecules in a
nucleosome Yi L and I had shown in 1987
that wrapping promoter DNA around
histones in the nucleosome prevents the
initiation of transcription in vitro and
Michael grinstein and colleagues showed
the very next year a similar inhibitory
effect of histones upon the initiation
of transcription in yeast cells in Vivo
on which basis we uh might M grinstein
and others came to believe what you
heard Mark say earlier the nucleosome
serves as a general Gene
repressor it prevents expression of all
the many thousands of genes and UK
carots except those whose expression is
brought about by specific positive
regulatory mechanisms again it would
seem apparent that any such mechanism
must entail at some stage the removal of
histones or the disruption of the
nucleosome uh in fact the late Ira hit a
great yeast yeast geneticist who uh died
unfortunately at a uh at a at a
unfortunate early age uh the IRA
herkowitz had uh intuited the existence
of the proteins responsible for removing
histones to allow transcription um from
genetic studies in yeast he uh concluded
or he deduced the existence of a
so-called switch sniff complex marker
also mentioned it in his lecture uh he
identified five genes which he believed
would comprise that would would compose
that complex and which would be
responsible for relieving the inhibition
of transcription by histones when uh
some years later my colleagues and I
isolated the switch niff complex from
yeast we could verify his hypothesis we
discovered it contained a number of
additional proteins one of which
so-called swap 7 3 uh we knew had a
homologue in the genome and then pursuit
of that homologue revealed another even
larger assembly of proteins uh which
like switch niff serves as a chromatin
remodeling complex um and plays a role
in removing histones for
transcription the switch niff complex is
in fact uh relatively scarce only about
a 100 molecules in a yeast cell and the
genes for switch niff proteins can be
deleted without uh effect upon
vegetative growth growth by contrast the
risk chromatin remodeling complex is
abundant on the order of a thousand
molecules per cell and the genes that
encoded are essential for cell
growth we uh discovered over the years
that followed uh two
important bio uh chromatin remodeling
activities of the risk complex risk in
the presence of ATP will slide histon
octomer and in that way expose a site
for interaction with a protein molecu
um risk in the presence of ATP and a
histone chaperon will actually dislodge
the histones from DNA and expose uh a
region of the DNA in that
manner we wanted uh to find out to
determine whether what I have told you
is the whole story um so is it true in
fact that uh risk enables the uh
initiation of transcription by the Paul
two transcription Machinery we wanted to
recapitulate the process starting from
chromin and culminating in transcription
with purified proteins in a cell-free
system now others uh in the Years Gone
by have performed experiments along
these lines they uh produced chromatin
by uh the addition of purified histones
to template DNA or with the use of
extracts from cells that would serve as
chroman assembly systems uh we thought
it was important uh
to pursue the problem with the use of
Chromatin assembled not in vitro in that
manner but as it is formed in cells in
Vivo uh after all we could not know uh
it has not yet been determined what is
the precise pattern of post transational
modifications of the histones of
nucleosomes associated with a promoter
um it is uh it was not known uh what
additional non-histone proteins might
play a role
uh and so with the purpose of
investigating as a template for
transcription chromatin uh isolated from
nature uh we uh performed the procedure
Illustrated in the uh in this slide so
we began uh following a protocol
invented by Mark gartenberg here at Yale
inserting uh sites for recognition by a
recombinase uh either side of a gene and
for these studies we studied the fa5
gene of yeast though was I'll tell you
the results are completely
General uh then by expression of the
recombinase in the yeast cells in Vivo
uh one brings about the excision of the
gene in this case F5 in the form of a
circle um still associated with the
natural set of chromosomal proteins the
circle could be isolated by Affinity
means we purified it to some 200,000
fold the virtual homogene
uh when shagi nagai said about
transcription with polymerase and the
general factors uh he found as we
expected no detectable transcription
from the gene isolated in the repressed
form as chromatin uh the same DNA
extracted from the chromatin would of
course give rise to measurable
transcription I I should say that an
experiment like this which nagat
performed was not straightforward
because of the extraordinarily small
quantity material we're isolating
chromatin from single copy genes means
we recover atom that is 10 the minus
18th molar quantities of Chromatin and
detection of transcription was a
challenge but which he nevertheless
overcame shagi then found that by the
addition of five more proteins the
activator protein for the fa5 gene
called
fo4 uh tf2s which was previously
regarded as a transcription elongation
Factor but we find is essential for
initiation the mediator that I've
mentioned another complex to which Mark
alluded The Saga
complex and a remodeling uh protein
complex which could be either switch
niff or risk in these
experiments now uh in the presence of
that group of proteins uh the chromatin
template was efficiently transcribed in
fact to our surprise to a far greater
extent than naked DNA extracted from the
chromatin Circle uh we had thought if we
were ultimately successful we would
achieve a level of transcription from
chromatin comparable to that from a
naked molecule but to our astonishment
the level of transcription from
chromatin was far greater and in fact as
the concentration of polymerase and the
general factors and other proteins was
reduced the ratio of transcription from
chromin to that from the naked DNA
molecule increased to the point where
where uh it was at least 20 fold greater
at the lowest concentration that we were
able to
use so this would indicate uh that
chromatin is better able to recruit um
so shows a higher affinity for the
proteins involved in transcription than
a naked DNA molecule which is a point
I'll return to in a moment I might
mention in passing that chromatin
transcription requires acety COA uh of
course naked DNA transcription does not
and also chromatin transcription
requires a subunit of The Saga complex
called
sgf29 so a form of saga deleted for that
complex shows significantly diminished
transcription uh from the chromatin
template so just to summarize what I've
told you to this point a transcription
from chromatin is a good deal greater
than that from a naked DNA molecule and
it increases relative to that from naked
DNA as the concentration of the
transcription Pro proteins uh decreases
which points to an interaction of
Chromatin and in particular as I'll show
you the nucleosome uh with the
transcription
machinery and then I just mentioned that
uh that interaction involves both histon
acetalation and the histone 3 K4
trimethyl Mark that is recognized by a
subunit of The Saga complex now we could
identify which nucleosome of the
chromatin template is involved in this
interaction uh by virtue of studies done
many years ago by wolf from Herz and
colleagues so Herz had shown that the
fa5 gene as you might imagine and as
Mark Illustrated in his diagrams is
packaged in an array of nucleosomes in
the repressed State uh Herz also showed
that upon transcriptional Activation so
upon induction of transcription of the
F5 Gene in yeast and Vivo two
nucleosomes are removed and one is
caused to slide it shifts in position
exposing the tatab box of the promoter
but still covering the transcription
start site now we could insert the sites
for recognition by the recombinase to
make chromatin circles upstream and
downstream of the promoter and in that
way isolate circles from the gene in the
repress state that would bear three
nucleus owns circles from the Gene and
the activated State bearing only a
single nucleus home located over the
transcription start site exposing the
tattoox we found still there was
enhanced transcription from the
chromatin template compared with the
naked DNA
molecule on this basis then we believe
contrary to what we had imagined that uh
the presence of a nucleosome covering
the transcription start side would be
inhibitory to transcription rather that
the nucleome covering the start site
commonly referred to as the plus one
nucleome is actually a component of the
transcription
Machinery we imagine uh that the
transcription Machinery we previously
thought comprised polymerase the general
factors and mediator uh now entails
assembly of a much larger complex uh
Beyond those 67 protein 57 proteins a
total of 99 a complex of over five
million Daltons uh again which must be
formed at every liat to promoter prior
to the initiation of transcription now I
said what we have observed for the fa5
gene abuse we believe to be General we
think it's applicable to all yeast genes
in fact to all genes of UK carots and
I'll explain now briefly why so this
picture which I have just shown you of a
single nucleome in the activated State
covering the transcription start site
flanking an exposed region is observed
throughout these genome so you see a
picture here of a type type of analysis
that has been reported by uh many
research groups this is our own version
of the same thing it's obtained by
mapping the locations of
nucleosomes um with the use of uh
cleavage between them by microcal
nucleus and then deep sequencing uh what
you see plotted in red is the likelihood
of occurrence of a nucleome as a
function of position along a 100 KB
region of one of the East chromosomes
also indicated below are the locations
of transcribed regions with the sites by
the plus signs if we zoom in on one
portion what you see what is uh through
throughout the genome namely uh an array
of
nucleosomes uh but with the apparent
absence of
one immediately Upstream of a
transcription start site um and then a
very well positioned
nucleus uh the socalled plus one
nucleome covering that site the
so-called free or nucleome free
region includes the tatab boox and
Regulatory elements um and those are
available for interaction with activator
or oppressor proteins and uh for the
beginning of assembly of the
transcription Machinery um in the
interest of time I won't uh comment on
the question that is posed here of what
is the basis of the NFR but I'll skip
directly uh to uh a
further uh and last topic of my
presentation I'll simply summarize what
I've told you up to this point in the
following way we think what emerges is
what I might call a two-step
authentication
mechanism for the turn on of
transcription uh a first step in
which uh a region that includes
regulatory elements in the tab box is
exposed but still leaving a nucleome
covering the start site and then a
second step that that requires that
nucleosome and culminates in the
initiation of
transcription um it's rather like the
immune system that requires two steps to
assure Fidelity of the response in this
case two steps uh and an intermediate in
which a nucleosome still covering a
start site prevents adventitious
initiation of
transcription uh now everything I've
told you to this point relates uh to
chrom chromatin at the only level we
presently understand namely an array of
nucleosomes uh which uh in as I've said
in the repress State and as Mark
emphasized as well uh more or less
uniformly packages the genomic DNA uh
the next slide will uh in a way
summarize our ignorance of the problem
so this is a picture many of you will
have seen uh an electron microscope thin
section of a eukariotic nucleus uh with
heterochromatin the condensed region
around the periphery so-called UK
chromatin in the interior I showed this
picture for 20 25 years uh to uh medical
students at Stanford when I taught
hystology to medical students and then
finally uh the Stanford Administration
and its wisdom eliminated basic science
from the medical curriculum and so uh I
don't have many opportunities of showing
it again I do so now uh for a particular
reason which is
uh uh to call attention to the question
of what is the organization
of chromosomal material in particular
what is the structure of a gene um in
interphase in a eukariotic cell
nucleus uh now I will tell you then only
briefly about experiments which I think
shed light on this question and they
come from our use of a method introduced
by others that you heard mentioned um
chromosome confirmation capture or in
its most elaborate form so-called high C
and the method is is very straight
forward it involves fixation with
formaly to cross link proteins cleavage
of the
DNA uh and then finally ligation of the
cut ends if the proteins have brought
together two regions located at distant
sights in the genome sequencing across
the junction will Reve will reveal their
proximity in the
chromosome and this has been done as I
say by um many others over the years and
this is just an example uh from work by
Decker and colleagues of the results
that are obtained um what you see here
each Red Dot that is plotted here um
corresponds to uh a point of of cross
linking so of approximation between uh a
location in the DNA sequence of the
chromosome plotted here and another
location in the same chromosome plotted
on the other AIS and what is revealed by
this type of analysis done in many
Laboratories are the this is such an
alternation of regions of int
chromosomal interaction and uh less such
int chromosomal contact it struck me
um such an alternation of interaction
and absence of such was reminiscent of
polyan chromosomes of
dropa and so we asked the question
whether uh the application of high SE
to uh dipin laral tissue containing
polyene chromosomes would produce a
similar result to what you saw in the
previous slide KY lean found
indeed uh
the uh
so-called topologically associating
domains or
tads could be detected when the
procedure was applied to salivary gland
tissue of the appropriate marble stage
of dropa and then what you see in the
next slide um is in the number of cases
where DNA sequence coordinates of bands
are known and in these cases those the
DNA of the Bands is lined up at the left
side um the amount of DNA in a band
varies in length and what you see in red
is the overlap with a tad revealed by
the high SE approach with the DNA
sequence coordinates of the band in
black or regions of nonoverlap well it's
obvious that there's almost a perfect
correspondence of uh tads with bands the
same thing could be applied so bands
equal tads and I might add what this
immediately uh reveals is something
significant about the interpretation of
a tad people had wondered are these uh
transient or do they represent stable
interactions uh do they relate to
regulation or do they relate to
structure what we learn uh from this
simple uh observation uh tads actually
correspond uh to regions of persistent
chromosomal condensation along the
length of the chromosome we could apply
the same procedure and it's plotted in a
similar manner to uh
the so-called highy or chromosome
confirmation capture analysis of diploid
cells and what emerges is that not only
are bands equivalent to polyan tads uh
but they're nearly the same as diploid
tads from which it emerges that the
picture of a chromosome that one
observes uh in the light
microscope uh from examination of polyan
tissue actually reveals the organization
of the chromosomal material in the
interphase nucleus of well in this case
uh cultured cells of dropa but virtually
the same result with embryonic tissue of
dropa
containing absolutely you see exactly
the same
resultes the same sorry twoes the same
on the contrary the band pattern which
is characteristic is you
form no the formal the formal is reveal
uh Crossing was a local result nothing
related to anything macroscopic on the
scale that you mentioned only uh at the
level of individual protein protein
contact so those experiments of course
done with squashing but it wouldn't
matter how range is that
poly the the range of the interaction
with polymos is exactly the same as the
range in diploid cells or in embryonic
tissue uh so I showed you that the tads
are typically notter of omab Bas in size
and that will be true throughout we
talked about this be sure there's no fat
contaminating
your well in the first place uh
the I of course I'm I absolutely don't
know the answer to that question all I
can tell you is that uh when salivary
glands are dissected they give this
result and it is equivalent to what is
found with KC cells of dropa and
equivalent to what is found with
embryonic tissue of
drop all I can tell
you now one can of course put a ruler to
the picture in the light microscope of a
poly chromosome and with knowledge of
the DNA coordinates from the deep
sequencing from the highy analysis uh
State rather precisely what is the
degree of compaction of the DNA along
the length of the chromosome and for
this purpose we actually took
measurements that were made Long Ago by
John
sedat and uh they reveal what is shown
here that in between the bands the
region uh referred to as interbands uh
the packing ratio defined as the length
of the DNA uh contained in that region
divided by The observed or measured
length of the fiber packing ratio is
between five and 10 and it just happens
that uh by now what 40 some odd years
ago when I uh put forward the idea of uh
the nucleosome I could calculate from
what I surmised to be the DNA content of
a nucleosome and the approximate
diameter of a particle calculated a
ratio of
6.8 uh so without any doubt what we have
in interbands are open chains extended
chromatin fibers we know from the
sequence analysis they came in about 5%
of the total DNA and within the endbands
reside for the most part the regulatory
sequences and promoters of dropa genes
uh those undergo
transcription uh
dropa
cytologists and geneticists identify two
types of bands they call gray and black
um and again by such measurements we
know that the gray bands have an
intermediate packing ratio between the
iner bands and black bands they
represent such fibers condensed some two
to 10 fold they contain about a quarter
of all the DNA and for the most part the
bodies of transcription aactive genes
and finally the black bands contain such
fibers now condensed 20 to 30 fo
the majority of the DNA and all and and
in every case genes that are not
transcribed so this gives some color to
the picture that I showed you before um
now we have a better idea of what is the
organization of the chromosome of
material um within the interphase
nucleus and in particular what is the
structure of a gene uh undergoing
transcription so I uh that is the
conclusion of what I have to say and I
know time is short and everybody wants
to hear what Sid will comment at the end
um I only wanted to reiterate what I
said at the beginning uh and to
emphasize uh something which I think is
often forgotten uh namely the insights
that Sid derive and everything that I've
told you uh comes not from studies of
human cells but but what we call model
organisms uh and I think that uh there's
still much to be learned from work on
these lines that The Best Is Yet To Come
uh congratulations Sid and thank you
all Roger a question that is coming up
all the time is a very differentiated
cell versus a non-differentiated cell
and if you can actually detect any
differences there so uh in in these
experiments we have not attempted to
detect such a difference uh but let me
add that uh it may be uh
helpful to mention polyan chromosomes of
course lack one uh feature that Mark
mentioned and that is common in very
many differentiated tissues it would be
an important property of what uh Tom
Anis alluded to before uh the looping of
chromosomal material to bring enhancers
at some distance and proximity to
promoters of course that's not possible
in a polyan chromosome because you have
a thousand copies lined up and they are
comparatively rigid and indeed one can
show that for example in the uh uh some
of the important lowside that exhibit
this I don't know in tedia or others
where this happens uh those uh features
are
detectable by this highy analysis in
cells of an appropriate origin the
differentiated cells where it occurs and
not in the polyan
chromosomes so what we look at in the
potin case is the if you were the basic
level of chromosomal organization of um
interphase nuclei in general there are
additional features that may be
superimposed in differentiated
tissues indeed I'd be glad to mention
that I just was worried about uh the
time but I'll I I'll I'll tell you in a
word in fact in fact I could probably go
back to it very quickly if that if if I
can get recover this but if not I'll
just say it in a word
um I think it's uh best not to try uh so
it had been suggested by many that the
uh mechanism of formation of a
nucleosome free region depended on the
abundance of at-rich DNA Mark alluded to
that point and it was thought that uh it
is a passive mechanism that it is
because of what had long been
known that at Rich DNA in particular
polyda poly DT is actually refractory to
the formation of a nucleosome it is
sufficiently rigid it won't bend around
the histone octomer to form a
nucleosome uh we tested that idea in a
straightforward way we discovered we
could form nucleosomes they had the
hison octomer had a comparable affinity
for nucleome free regions from yeast as
for DNA derived from the bodies of genes
uh we went on to show that if we
assemble a nucleus on DNA from a
nucleosome free
region um and side by side DNA coming
from for example an open reading frame
that the risk remodeling complex would
remove the
nucleosome at least in order of
magnitude more rapidly uh from the NFR
and then finally we could show that if
we start with uh a nucleosome assembled
on D DNA that is of uh typical origin
and has no uh significant aloda alod
stretches for example uh risk would
remove a nucleome only very slowly if we
insert simply a seven residue stretch of
aligo daa oligodt then the nucleome is
rapidly removed so indeed as people have
suggested uh the presence of at
sequences plays a role but not through a
passive rather an active mechanism it's
something which is controlled it's ATP
dependent and it involves the function
of the risk chromin remodeling
[Applause]
[Music]
complex